[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing dragons
more specifically we're going to be
ranking the most powerful dragons by you
guessed it power i've made lots of these
ranking videos in the past ranking
slytherins hufflepuffs ravenclaws
gryffindors auras order of the phoenix
members dumbledore's army members and
more i've even ranked the most powerful
magical beasts a list where dragons made
it to the number two spot losing out to
well you've got to watch that video to
find out anyway you guys seem to always
enjoy them so i thought why not rank one
of the most powerful beasts in the
wizarding world dragons pop up in the
harry potter films quite a bit and are
frequently referred to as some of the
most powerful creatures in existence
they play a prevalent role in the harry
potter story and their name is even
nestled into the hogwarts motto dracul
dormian nan kwame titilandus which means
never tickle a sleeping dragon dragons
are giant winged fire-breathing beasts
as incite fear in the hearts of even the
bravest witches and wizards and it's for
this reason they're classified as
category 5x beasts by the ministry of
magic
in essence this classification means
they are nearly impossible to
domesticate and that historically they
have been known to kill witches wizards
there is certainly no shortage of types
of dragons in the wizarding world and
they all have their own unique traits
that set them apart so ranking them
should be fun before we get started
comment your own top 7 down below then
watch the video and see how they match
up
number seven ibritian black the
hybridian black is a native dragon to
britain sharing the area with the common
welsh green however the hybridian black
is much more dangerous
the hybridian black is a large
intimidating rough-scale dragon with the
razor-sharp ridges along its back bat
like wings and a spiked tail it can grow
up to 30 feet long and has glaring
purple eyes the hybridian black resides
in the hebrides islands in scotland and
can usually be found there feasting on
cows and its favorite freshly sourced
venison number six romanian longhorn the
romanian longhorn is a medium large
sized dragon with dark green skin
and consistent with its name
two long golden horns it is a native
dragon to romania where charlie weasley
works for the romanian dragon sanctuary
the romanian longhorn is particularly
muscular and its horns jets straight out
of its head like a bull it uses these
horns to gouge its prey however while it
is a particularly intimidating looking
dragon it is worth mentioning they're
not particularly aggressive
unfortunately the romanian longhorn
population is relatively low and that's
because their horns have such a high
value this makes them a common target
for poachers this is even referenced on
a chocolate frog card the horns of this
breed of dragon are highly valued as
potions ingredients and as a result his
numbers have fallen in recent years on a
positive note longhorns are now the
subjects of intensive breeding programs
in an effort to recoup their dwindling
numbers
number five chinese fireball the chinese
fireball aka the lion dragon is a medium
large sized dragon between two and four
tons that dwells in all sorts of
landscapes the dragon is native to china
and primarily presides there the chinese
fireball is known to be more
accommodating about sharing its
territory than some other dragons the
fireball is scarlet coloured with smooth
scales and golden spikes
it also has particularly piercing eyes
the fireball part of its name comes from
the balls of flame that it shoots out of
its nostrils balls that appear to be
almost mushroom shaped the breed is
notably aggressive towards well
everything apart from its own kind
victor crum notably faces a chinese
fireball in the triwizard tournament
attempting to retrieve a golden egg that
it was protecting the chinese fireball
keeps trim with a relatively modest diet
of pigs and humans number four ukrainian
iron belly the ukrainian iron belly is a
monster of a dragon and the largest
known breed of dragon it is stated that
the ukrainian iron belly can reach a
weight of up to six tons which is at
least two to three times the weight of
most of the dragons in this list it has
metallic grey scales deep red eyes and
long vicious razor sharp talons the iron
belly's sheer mass means that it is slow
but it's dangerous nonetheless as its
sheer mass causes it to crush anyone and
everything that it lands near
apparently once one of these dragons was
able to take off while carrying an
entire vacant sailboat notably the
lestrange vault inside of gringotts was
garnered by a ukrainian iron belly and
was subsequently set free by harry
potter in 1998 during their escape from
gringotts the iron belly is mentioned in
the fantastic beasts films as well when
newt mentions to jacob that he worked
with iron valleys during the first world
war number three peruvian vipertooth the
peruvian viper tooth is the smallest of
the dragons but is extremely dangerous
and highly venomous the average adult is
approximately 15 feet in length which
compared to the 50-foot horned tail is
not particularly large but that
certainly doesn't mean that they aren't
a threat the viper tooth was once a
substantial threat to wizard kind as
they were reproducing at an alarming
rate their bite is particularly venomous
and these copper-coloured customers love
chewing on human flesh they are
smooth-scaled with copper-coloured black
ridge markings short horns and long
fangs the viper tooth usually eats goats
and cows but it has been expressed that
they have a particular craving for
humans number two norwegian ridgeback
the norwegian ridgeback goes by another
name
norbert aka norberta the norwegian
ridgeback is a rarer breed of dragon and
resembles the horntail in a lot of ways
the main exception is that the ridgeback
has black ridges on its back and a
browner quality to its scales the
ridgeback is known to prey on large
mammals even water mammals and it was
reported in 1802 that a norwegian
ridgeback was seen carrying a whale calf
in its mouth off the coast of norway to
add to all of this the ridgeback has a
very toxic bite and develops fire
breathing capabilities very early on in
this series hackard receives a ridgeback
egg from a stranger in the pub after he
hatches hagrid named him norbert hagrid
eventually has to give up norbert and
gives him to charlie weasley who takes
him to the romanian dragon sanctuary
it's later discovered by charlie weasley
that norbert was in fact a girl
later renaming her norberta apparently
he was able to tell that alberto was a
girl by how much more vicious the female
ridgebacks are
norbert the norwegian ridgeback we call
her norberta now what robert's a girl
oh yeah how can you tell they're a lot
more vicious number one hungarian
horntail the hungarian horntail is
widely considered to be the most
dangerous of all dragon breeds and harry
famously faces one in the tri-wizard
tournament newt's commander author
fantastic beasts and where to find them
admitted himself that the horntail is
the most dangerous of the dragon breeds
and he certainly knows his magical
beasts the horntail is enormous and has
a lizard-like appearance along with
bronze horns spikes that protrude from
its long tail and yellow eyes with
vertical pupils it is known to have one
of the longest fire breathing ranges and
can scorch you from 50 feet away hagrid
had this to say about dragons in general
oh don't worry about them harry they're
seriously misunderstood creatures
although i have to admit that horntail
is a right nasty piece of work perhaps
the scariest aspect of the horntail is
the double threat that it poses with a
powerful flamethrower on its front and a
spiked club on its back
charlie weasley once remarked that its
back ends as dangerous as its front and
that's it for this list honorable
mentions include the swedish short snout
common welsh green and antipodean opal
eye did i miss any powerful dragons that
deserve to be on this list would you
change up the order comment down below
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time
fascinating but misunderstood beasts
harry fascinating but misunderstood